j'attendais une place pour me garer les
feux de détresse et celui sympa musette
de l'heure chez moi pas être devant chez
moi je vais ça arrive pile on commence à
être sympa arrange enlève pas allé non
pourquoi parce que
la loi c'est la loi et la louange
beaucoup de la loire là bas voilà je
vous paye un coup si vous voulez je vous
donne une pièce à la bonne heure ok bon
bras
des mois 50 fois on en parlait de javel
la cliente manière mais moins 50 des
accidents cheval la crise a le droit de
faire ça je sais pas mais en tout cas je
le prends vous avez loin vous de
regarder comme un cochon allez si moi je
suis crevée mois
n'est pas le cas c'est un crève je vais
aller voir les flics pour quoi faire bon
portefeuille contre vous maintenant pour
quoi faire et mon truc attention tout
soit en outre que ces cas c'est fragile